[Music]
[Applause]
so i want to start by um offering you a
free
no tech life hack
um and all it requires of you is this
that you change your posture
for two minutes but before i give it
away i want to ask you to right now do a
little audit of your body and what
you're doing with your body so how many
of you are sort of making yourself
smaller maybe you're hunching
um crossing your legs maybe wrapping
your ankles sometimes we hold on to our
arms like this
sometimes we
spread out
i see you
so i want you to pay attention to what
you're doing right now we're going to
come back to that in a few minutes and
i'm hoping that if you sort of learn to
tweak this a little bit it could
significantly change the way your life
unfolds um
so we're really fascinated with body
language and we're particularly
interested in other people's body
language you know we're interested in
like you know
um
a uh
uh an awkward interaction or a smile or
a contemptuous glance or maybe a very
awkward wink
or maybe even something like a handshake
here they are arriving at number 10 and
uh look at this lucky policeman gets to
shake hands with the president of the
united states on here comes the prime
minister of it
now
so um a handshake or the lack of a
handshake can have us talking for weeks
and weeks and weeks even the bbc in the
new york times so so obviously when we
think about nonverbal behavior or body
language but we call it nonverbals as
social scientists it's language so we
think about communication when we think
about communication we think about
interactions so what is your body
language communicating to me what's mine
communicating to you and there's a lot
of reason to be to believe that this is
this is a valid way to look at this so
social scientists have spent a lot of
time
looking at the effects of of our body
language or other people's body language
on judgments and we make sweeping
judgments and inferences from body
language and those judgments can predict
really meaningful life outcomes like who
we hire or promote um who we ask out on
the date for example
uh nalani ambadi a researcher at tufts
university shows that when people watch
30 minute a 30 second soundless clips of
real physician patient interactions
their judgments of the physician's
niceness
predict whether or not that physician
will be sued so it doesn't have to do so
much with whether or not that physician
was incompetent but do we like that
person and how they interacted um
even more dramatic alex todorov at
princeton has shown us that
judgments of political candidates faces
in just one second predict 70 percent of
u.s senate and gubernatorial race
outcomes
and even let's go digital emoticons
used well in online negotiations can
lead you to claim more value from that
negotiation if you use them poorly bad
idea right so
so when we think of nonverbals we think
of how we judge others how they judge us
and what the outcomes are we tend to
forget though the other audience that's
influenced by our nonverbals and that's
ourselves we are also influenced by our
non-verbals our thoughts and our
feelings and our physiology so
what nonverbals am i talking about i'm a
social psychologist
i study prejudice
and i teach at a competitive business
school so
it was inevitable that i would become
interested in power dynamics i became
especially interested in non-verbal
expressions of power and dominance
and what are nonverbal expressions of
power and dominance well
this is what they are so in the animal
kingdom they are about expanding so you
make yourself big you stretch out you
take up space you're basically opening
up it's about opening up and this is
true across the animal kingdom it's not
just limited to primates
and humans do the same thing
so they do this both when they when they
have power sort of chronically and also
when they're feeling powerful in the
moment and this one is especially
interesting because it really shows us
how universal and old these expressions
of power are this expression which is
known as pride
jessica tracy has studied she shows that
people who are born with sight and
people who are congenitally blind
do this when they win at a physical
competition so when they cross the
finish line and they've won it doesn't
matter if they've never seen anyone do
it they do this
so the arms up in the v the chin is
slightly lifted
what do we do when we feel powerless we
do exactly the opposite we close up we
wrap ourselves up we make ourselves
small we don't want to bump into the
person next to us so again both animals
and humans do the same thing
and this is what happens when you put
together high and low power so what we
tend to do
when it comes to power is that we
complement the others non-verbals so if
someone's being really powerful with us
we tend to make ourselves smaller we
don't mirror them we do the opposite of
them
so
i'm watching this behavior in the
classroom
and
what do i notice i notice that
mba students
really exhibit the full range of power
nonverbal so you have people who are
like caricatures of alphas like really
come into the room they get right into
the middle of the room before class even
starts like they really want to occupy
space when they sit down they're sort of
spread out they raise their hands like
this
you have other people who are virtually
collapsing when they come in as soon as
they come in you see it you see it on
their faces and their bodies and they
sit in their chair and they make
themselves tiny and they go like this
when they raise their hand
i notice a couple things about this one
you're not going to be surprised it
seems to be related to gender
so
women are much more likely to do this
kind of thing than men
women feel chronically less powerful
than men so this is not surprising
but the other thing i noticed is that it
also seemed to be related to the extent
to which the students were participating
and how well they were participating and
this is really important in the mba
classroom because participation counts
for half a grade
so
business schools have been struggling
with its gender grade gap you get these
equally qualified women and men coming
in
and then you get these differences and
grades and it seems to be partly
attributable to participation
so i started to wonder you know okay so
you have these people coming in like
this and they're participating is it
possible that we could get people to
fake it and would it lead them to
participate more so my main collaborator
dana carney
who's at berkeley and i really wanted to
know can you fake it till you make it
like can you do this just for a little
while and actually experience a
behavioral outcome that makes you seem
more powerful so we know that our
non-verbals govern how other people
think and feel about us there's a lot of
evidence but our question really was
do our non-verbals govern how we think
and feel about ourselves
there's some evidence that they do so
for example um
when we we smile when we feel happy but
also when we're forced to smile by
holding a pen in our teeth like this
it makes us feel happy
so it goes both ways when it comes to
power
um
it also goes both ways so when you when
you uh feel powerful you're more likely
to do this but it's also possible
that um when you when you
pretend to be powerful you are more
likely to actually feel powerful
so the second question really was you
know
so we know that our minds change our
bodies but is it also true that that our
bodies change our minds
and when i say minds in the case of the
powerful what am i talking about so i'm
talking about thoughts
and feelings and the sort of
physiological things that make up our
thoughts and feelings and in my case
that's hormones i look at hormones so
what do the minds of the powerful versus
the powerless look like
so powerful people
tend to be not surprisingly more
assertive and more confident
more more optimistic they actually feel
that they're going to win even at games
of chance
they also tend to be able to think more
abstractly so there are a lot of
differences they take more risks there
are a lot of differences between
powerful and powerless people
physiologically there also our
differences on two
key hormones
testosterone which is the dominance
hormone
and cortisol which is the stress hormone
so
what we find is that
um
a high power alpha males and primate
hierarchies have high testosterone and
low cortisol
and
powerful and effective leaders also have
high testosterone and low cortisol so
what does that mean when you think about
power 10 people tended to think only
about testosterone because that was
about dominance but really power is also
about how you react to stress so do you
want the high power leader that's
dominant high on testosterone but really
stress reactive probably not right you
want the person
who's powerful and assertive and
dominant but not very stress reactive
the person who's laid back
so
we know that
in
in private hierarchies if an alpha needs
to take over uh if an individual needs
to take over an alpha role sort of
suddenly
within a few days that individual's
testosterone has gone up significantly
and his cortisol has dropped
significantly so we have this evidence
both that the body can shape the mind at
least at the facial level
and also
that role changes can shape the mind so
what happens okay you take a role change
what happens if you do that at a really
minimal level like this tiny
manipulation this tiny intervention for
two minutes you say i want you to stand
like this and it's going to make you
feel more powerful
so
this is what we did we decided to bring
people into the lab and run a little
experiment and these people adopted for
two minutes
either
high power poses or low power poses and
i'm just going to show you five of the
poses although they took on on two
so here's one
a couple more
this one has been dubbed the wonder
woman by the media
here a couple more
so you can be standing or you can be
sitting
and here are the low power poses so
you're folding up you're making yourself
small
this one is very low power when you're
touching your neck you're really kind of
protecting yourself
so
this is what happens they come in they
spit into a vial
we for two minutes say you need to do
this or this they don't look at pictures
of the poses we don't want to prime them
with a concept of power we want them to
be feeling power right so two minutes
they do this
we then ask them how powerful do you
feel on a series of items and then we
give them an opportunity to gamble
and then we take another saliva sample
that's it that's the whole experiment so
this is what we find risk tolerance
which is the gambling what we find is
that when you're not when the when
you're in the high power pose condition
86 of you will gamble when you're in the
low power post condition only 60 and
that's a pretty whopping significant
difference
here's what we find on testosterone
from their baseline when they come in
high-powered people experience about a
20 increase
and low power people experience about a
10 decrease so again two minutes and you
get these changes
here's what you get on cortisol
high power people experience about a 25
decrease
and the low power people experience
about a 15
increase so two minutes lead to these
hormonal changes that configure your
brain to basically be either
assertive confident and comfortable
or really stress reactive
and you know feeling sort of shut down
and we've all had that feeling right
so
it seems that our nonverbals do govern
how we think and feel about ourselves so
it's not just others but it's also
ourselves
also our bodies change our minds
but the next question of course is can
power posing for a few minutes really
change your life in meaningful ways so
this is in the lab it's this little task
you know it's just a couple of minutes
you know where can you actually apply
this which we cared about of course
and so we think it's really what what
what matters i mean where you want to
use this is evaluative situations like
social threat situations where are you
being evaluated either by your friends
like for teenagers at the lunchroom
table it could be you know for some
people speaking at a school board
meeting it might be giving a pitch or
giving a talk like this or
doing a job interview we decided that
the one that most people could relate to
because most people had been through was
the job interview so
um we published these these findings and
the media are all over and they say um
okay so this is what you do when you go
in for the job interview right
you know so we were of course horrified
and said oh my god no no no that's not
what we meant at all for
numerous reasons no no no don't do that
again this is not about you talking to
other people it's you talking to
yourself what do you do before you go
into a job interview you do this right
you're sitting down you're looking at
your iphone or your android not trying
to leave anyone out um you are you know
you're looking at your notes you're
hunting up making yourself small when
really what you should be doing maybe is
this like in the bathroom right do that
find two minutes so that's what we want
to test okay so we bring people into a
lab and they do a cup they do either
higher low power poses again they go
through a very stressful job interview
it's five minutes long they are being
recorded they're being judged also and
the judges
are trained to give no nonverbal
feedback so they look like this like
imagine this is the person interviewing
you
so for five minutes nothing and this is
worse than being heckled people hate
this it's it's what marianne lafrance
calls standing in social quicksand so
this really spikes your cortisol so this
is the job interview we put them through
because we really wanted to see what
happened we then have these coders look
at these tapes four of them they're
blind to the hypothesis they're blind to
the conditions they have no idea who's
been posing in what pose
and they
they end up
looking at these sets of tapes and they
say oh we want to hire these people all
the high power posers we don't want to
hire these people
we also evaluate these people much more
positively overall
but what's driving it it's not about the
content of the speech it's about the
presence that they're bringing to the
speech we also because we rate them on
all these variables related to sort of
competence like how well structured is
the speech how good is it what are their
qualifications no effect on those things
this is what's affected these kinds of
things
people are bringing their true selves
basically they're bringing themselves
they bring their ideas but as themselves
with no you know residue over them so
this is what's driving the effect or
media mediating the effect
so
um when i tell people about this
that our bodies change our minds and our
minds can change our behavior and our
behavior can change our outcomes they
say to me
i don't it feels fake right so i said
fake it till you make it like i don't
it's not me like i don't want to get
there and then still feel like a fraud i
don't want to feel like an imposter i
don't want to get there only to feel
like i'm not supposed to be here
and
that really resonated with me because i
want to tell you a little story about
being an imposter and feeling like i'm
not supposed to be here
when i was 19
i was in a really bad car accident i was
thrown out of a car
rolled several times i was thrown from
the car
and i woke up in a head injury rehab
ward
and i had been withdrawn from college
and i learned that my iq had dropped by
two standard deviations
which was um
very traumatic i knew my iq because i
had identified with being smart and i
had been called gifted as a child so i'm
taken out of college i keep trying to go
back they say you're not gonna finish
college like just you know
there's there are other things for you
to do but that's not gonna work out for
you
so
i really struggled with this and i have
to say having your identity taken from
you your core identity and if for me it
was being smart
having that taken from you there's
nothing that leaves you feeling more
powerless than that
so i felt entirely powerless i worked
and worked and worked and i got lucky
and worked and got lucky and worked
eventually i graduated from college
took me four years longer than my peers
and i convinced someone my my angel
advisor susan fisk to take me on and so
i ended up at princeton and i was like i
am not supposed to be here i am an
imposter and the night before my first
year talking the first year talk at
princeton is a 20-minute talk to 20
people that's it
i was so afraid of being found out the
next day that i called her and said i'm
quitting
she was like you are not quitting
because i took a gamble on you and
you're staying you're going to stay and
this is what you're going to do you're
going to fake it you're going to take
you're going to do every talk that you
ever get asked to do you're just gonna
do it and do it and do it even if you're
terrified and just paralyzed and having
an out-of-body experience until you have
this moment where you say
oh my gosh i'm doing it like i have
become this i am actually doing this so
that's what i did five years in grad
school a few years you know i'm at
northwestern i moved to harvard i'm at
harvard i'm not really thinking about it
anymore but for a long time i had been
thinking not supposed to be here not
supposed to be here so at the end of my
first year at harvard
a student who had not talked in class
the entire semester who had said look
you've got to participate or else you're
going to fail
came into my office i really didn't know
her at all
and she said
she came in totally defeated and she
said
i'm not supposed to be here
and that was the moment for me because
two things happened one was that i
realized
oh my gosh i don't feel like that
anymore
you know
i don't feel that anymore but she does
and i get that feeling and the second
was she is supposed to be here like she
can fake it she can become it so he's
like
yes you are you are supposed to be here
and tomorrow you're gonna fake it you're
gonna make yourself powerful and you
know
you're gonna
and
you're gonna go you're gonna go into the
classroom and you are gonna give the
best comment ever you know and she gave
the best comment ever and people turned
around they were like oh my god i didn't
even notice her sitting there you know
she comes back to me months later and i
realized that she had not just faked it
till she made it she had actually faked
it till she became it so she had changed
um and so i i i want to say to you don't
fake it till you make it fake it till
you become it
you know it's not do it enough until you
actually become it and internalize the
last thing i want to leave you with is
this
tiny tweaks
can lead to big changes
so
this is two minutes two minutes two
minutes two minutes before you go into
the next stressful evaluative situation
for two minutes try doing this in the
elevator in a bathroom stall at your
desk behind closed doors that's what you
want to do get configure your brain to
cope the best in that situation get your
testosterone up get your quarters all
down don't leave that situation feeling
like oh i didn't show them who i am
leave that situation feeling like i
really feel like i got to say who i am
and show who i am so i want to ask you
first you know
both to
try power posing
and also i want to ask you to share this
science because this is simple i don't
have ego involved in this
give it away like share it with people
because the people who can use it the
most are the ones with no resources and
no technology and no status and no power
give it to them because they can do it
in private they need their bodies
privacy and two minutes and it can
significantly change the outcomes of
their life thank you
[Music]
you